what about learning how to see the
project on a time line learning how to
cut do dissolve just different things
like that yeah I've always said I think
those are the two sort of bookends of
being a great director is and I mean a
great director in the sense of being a
director who is doing what the job says
which is direct in order to direct a
movie to make sure it comes out the way
you want it to you have to understand
somewhat ography and on the other end
you have to understand editing if you
can understand those two things and do
as much of that as you possibly can in
the beginning edit yourself then you
will be able to direct an editor you'll
be able to say no that cut should come
ten frames later and you'll be able to
you'll be able to guide an editor to and
that all important step of make putting
those images together in the way that
you see them in your mind again too many
people I think too many young filmmakers
even too many students go well I'm gonna
get an editing student to cut my film my
student film and you're like yeah but
not yet like do you cut it first cut it
first it may not be as great I may not
be as finessed as that editing student
who is only thinking about that but
unless you get again familiar with
putting two shots together and seeing
what works and what doesn't work you're
never going to feel confident giving
notes to an editor because you'll just
you'll be like how a lot of producers
who are not savvy in that way are you're
just going well just make it good you
know lead I'm gonna when I wake up in
the morning there'll be an edit and
it'll be a movie but I don't know how it
happened but I just know you know it's
like it's like when you pick an art like
it's you don't want it to be like how I
look at like an auto mechanic which is
just like I want an auto mechanic will
just make the car work and I don't want
to know what the hell you did just make
it work so many producers think that way
if your director and think that way I
think if you have this mindset that
somebody else should do this work and
you're not you're not clear on how it
was accomplished and I mean that by way
of editing then you're being willfully
ignorant and you're putting yourself at
a disadvantage as a director because
that doesn't
to me a director has a real
understanding of working a working
knowledge of all the departments
he just doesn't he doesn't sit there and
and hope that these the cinematographer
tells him what the shot should be he
shouldn't wait for the costume designer
to tell him what the / what the actor
should wear or the production audition
and say what color the walls are you can
interact with those people and but you
need to guide them and say this is what
I'm this is what I'm thinking up here's
a storyboard this is what I'm thinking
of this is the kind of jacket I want
this I'm not sure if it should be this
pattern but this is from this period is
what I'm thinking of because then you
set these very talented people on a path
and they can build on that but if you
don't give them those those those sort
of foundational elements or information
then other people start inventing your
movie for you and then you just sit back
and go yeah I kind of like that I don't
know I don't like that and a lot of
movies get made that way yeah a lot of
movies get made that way but they don't
have that distinctive mark that's why
certain films you'll see a certain film
you'll see a Kubrick movie and you know
that he picked that ashtray you know the
one that's like way in the background
you know that he was out of focus you
know that not only did he picked that
ashtray but he moved it two inches to
the left just to make sure that the
image was exact you know that's the
difference you know I think you feel
that difference too
do you remember editing your first
project how was that was this you were
splicing or no yeah splicing yeah they
when I was editing well I mean I was
when I was in film school it was a lot
easier to cut silent 16 millimeter
footage because then you were just
really just dealing with you know just
the picture element and yes you had to
cut that you know cut that with a rivas
splicer and you got to use tape splicing
and you put it up on a flatbed it was
certainly a more time-consuming process
and when you when we moved into sound it
was more complicated because but still
the same thing because you're dealing
with a separate sound element on mag and
you have to make sure that's kept in
sync and it's harder if you want
overlapping dialogue or anything you
can't just split it up on audio channel
1 & 2 now you've got it like you've got
to thread up a whole new
piece of MAG and it's a whole other
thing but it was more time-consuming but
what it did teach you was to be
thoughtful in your editing because it
was such a pain in the ass to undo it so
like when you made that cut you were
thinking about yeah this yeah should it
be here should be here here like you
made really made a thoughtful edit
because if you threaded it up and you
looked at it it was wrong then it was a
hole of Boreas process of untape
untape in your sound finding those five
frames that are now hanging on a trim
bin cut those in you know like it was
just like a long so what it did I think
it taught a lot of editors to be more of
a thinking because the indeed the result
of a bad or a thoughtless edit was just
took more time of course now the
consequences of making a bad at it or
easily you just undo you know you just
hit undo and you're it's easy but yeah I
mean it was like anything I mean editing
was like a bungle II you know technical
like how do we do this how do we keep it
in sync and all the things that happen
now but again with familiarity comes and
ease and then you don't have to worry so
much about the technical part of it all
you're worried about all you're thinking
about is how how to make the best
creative choice and I think that's true
of anything I mean must be true of
learning a musical instrument you know
when you're learning a musical
instrument you're just you know we're
you're just trying to read music you're
just trying to you know hit the right
key that means and then later it's like
language you're fluent in it you don't
think about it as much anymore so I
think it's important to do it yourself
to get over that fear and become fluent
in the language and then then you can
direct you know
you